besprechen wir das ganze jetzt bei uns
im Studio mit Michael rot von der SPD er
ist der Vorsitzende vom Auswärtigen
Ausschuss schönen guten Morgen herzlich
Willkommen bei uns guten Morgen Frau
waldenfelz Kanzler Scholz hat gestern
vor Abflug Richtung Washington noch
einmal betont man müsste jetzt Richtung
Putin das Signal senden dass die
Unterstützung aus dem Westen nicht
bröckelt ist das möglicherweise auch
deswegen nötig weil es eben doch im
Westen mittlerweile gewisse
abstumpfunkserscheinung gibt ja die gibt
es der trumpismus breitet sich aus das
Gift äh von Donald Trump wirkt unter
anderem in den USA die USA sind der mit
weitem Abstand wichtigste Verbündete der
Ukraine die USA haben maßgeblich mit
beiden an der Spitze dazu beigetragen
dass die
Ukraine diesen Freiheitskampf zu
bestehen vermag und wenn die USA
ausfallen sollte wird das ganz ganz
schwierig die Lage ist beschissen aber
nicht hoffnungslos wenn wir
Europäerinnen und Europäer jetzt das
kompensieren was von der USA
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr kommt mehr
Waffen schneller liefern auf der auf dem
Weltmarkt Einkaufen nicht mehr allein
auf die europäische Rüstungsindustrie
setzen okay dann gehen wir diese
Schritte noch mal ganz kurz durch ein
bisschen genauer also ein Schritt zurück
noch mal zu den USA für wie
wahrscheinlich halten sie es denn dass
da kein Geld fließt weil die Blockade
eben weiter bestehen bleibt der
amerikanische Präsident kämpft ja seit
Monaten tapfer um eine Mehrheit zu
bilden aber ich habe den Eindruck dass
das in so ideologisiert ist dass
Sicherheitsfragen der USA gar nicht mehr
die Rolle spielen sondern dass es nur
darum geht unhalt zu stiften für Unruhe
in Washington und in Amerika zu sorgen
vor allem auch einen Spaltpilz größer
werden zu lassen zwischen Europa und den
USA und dahinter steht natürlich Donald
Trump und seine furchtbare Ideologie
jetzt hat sich die EU ja nach sehr
langem Gezerre auf 50 Milliarden
Wirtschaftshilfen geeinigt wenn das aus
den USA die Unterstützung wegbricht dann
wird das ja nicht reichen das können wir
nicht kompensieren was passiert dann das
reicht bei weitem nicht dann gibt es
zwei Möglichkeiten entweder wir nehmen
das Modell was wir schon mal mit Erfolg
gefahren haben als wir die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Folgen der
Pandemie gemeinsam in Europa bekämpft
haben mit einem gemeinsamen Fond dass
wir so etwas wieder auflegen Schulden
finanziert weil das wird die
Möglichkeiten der EU beweiten
übersteigen und wir werden mit diesen
Mitteln dann schnell das Einkaufen was
die Ukraine braucht und wir werden damit
auch den Wiederaufbau der Ukraine zu
finanzieren haben und wenn das nicht
funktioniert brauchen wir eine Koalition
der ukrainischen Solidarität dass
europäische Staaten die deutlich mehr
liefern wollen und mehr tun wollen und
müssen sich zusammenschließen vielleicht
noch mal ganz kurz der Blick darauf dass
Scholz auch Vertreter des US-Kongresses
ja getroffen hat also beider Parteien
kann der deutsche Bundeskanzler da
irgendwas bewirken also der
Bundeskanzler ist sicherlich ein Meister
in der argumentativen druckbetankung ob
es am Ende was was hilft bei wie gesagt
Fragen die sehr stark von Ideologie und
nicht von guten Argumenten geprägt sind
weiß ich nicht ein Versuch ist es alle
mal wert dann der Blick nach vorne auf
die anstehenden
US-Präsidentschaftswahlen ist ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass Donald Trump wieder
Präsident wird dann wird's mit der Hilfe
noch wackliger aber auch mit unserer
Partnerschaft was die NATO angeht was
würde das für uns bedeuten wenn das auf
der Kippe steht das wäre dann um es mal
positiv zu formulieren die zweite
Zeitenwende dann werden wir in Europa
aus der kuschligen woldecke der USA
befreit im wsen des Wortes und werden
uns selbst um unsere eigene Sicherheit
und Verteidigung in Europa zu kümmern
haben das wird sehr viel Geld sehr viel
Kraft kosten aber es bleibt uns am Ende
des Tages nichts anderes übrig also sie
sagen es geht dann um mehr
Eigenverantwortung der Europäer dazu
gehört natürlich auch
dass Deutschland das abgemachte 2% Ziel
der NATO einhält also ein Puzzel Teil
von vielen bedeutet eben 2% des
bruttoinlands Produktes für Verteidigung
auszugeben wenn man davon ausgeht dass
2028 das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr aufgebraucht ist wie soll das
dann funktionieren Frau walenfels wenn
Trump wirklich die Bündnisverpflichtung
in der NATO aufkündigen sollte dann
reden wir nicht mehr über 100 Milliarden
Euro Sondervermögen dann reden wir auch
nicht mehr über 2% Wirtschaftsleistung
die wir dann in unsere eigene
Verteidigung und in die Bündnisfähigkeit
der NATO investieren dann werden wir
deutlich mehr Geld investieren müssen
nicht nur wir in Deutschland sondern
auch und vor allem unsere europäischen
Partner Michael rot war das der
Vorsitzende des Auswärtigen Ausschusses
von der SPD ganz herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch vielen Dank danke Ihnen